that's absolutely dipping hello everyone
all right don't say hello to be dad say
hello to our loving audience there right
there
oh yeah hi cinnamon challenge oh I've
never done the cinnamon challenge I've
never done it I mean it done obviously
the entire internet has seen the entire
internet coughing and choking on Sarah
yeah
so let me where's your spirit pocketed
nice bit of cinnamon how bad can this be
okay
people like doing it for chunk
except you Chandra from it slow motion
okay all in and I'll try and swallow it
you really yeah
[Music]
glad you find this funny so how do you
feel about all the people that done the
cinnamon challenge
[Music]
you know what though it's over you have
to do it now I don't want you doing it I
still feel like AIDS yeah yeah I reckon
you're being a big baby and I'll just be
able to swallow it just fine ya know
down the hatch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my light
oh that was bad yeah was was that as bad
as you thought it was gonna be a lot I
feel like all the fluid in my head is
try to evacuate I might throw up puked a
little bit well thanks for watching that
video you got on your face there lunch
be sure to follow us on Twitter I know
that is the worst in the world what
watch the next video I'm never doing
that again
[Music]
right that was a mistake that was a
mistake